remember that tory lanez and meghan the
stallion this is funny to me he shot him
the feed said dance [ __ ] yeah hey what
did he do that's what a cop saying a cop
saying that that's what happened he did
yeah he should but he shot at her not in
there
and then accidentally
supposedly allegedly accidentally
shot her feet yeah i saw the pictures
now i know it looked crazy
she was definitely shocked she graduated
college yeah she graduated college
recently she's super excited yeah but
that's still that's no joke he shot her
in the [ __ ] feet yeah look at her
feet she's dancing
it was weird at first
um apparently he was in a like drunken
rage he there was a phone call
to her best friend at the time who was
also in the car with them because it was
tory lanez megan stallion her best
friend at the time and then total lane
security guard who was driving and so
there was a drunken phone call
that ensued with uh megan the stallion's
former best friend and uh tori lanes
where he apologized like sorry i was
drunk that night i should have done that
you were drunk but then he doesn't admit
to shooting her and being that being the
reason why he's apologizing so his
lawyers are trying to say you don't know
what he's apologizing for he's just
apologizing to this girl yeah [ __ ] it's
terrible man this kind of went away too
i was like something has to happen to
twilight's we just kind of went away
well he was [ __ ] up for a while
because he went
on a music festival that meghan the
stallion was performing at and he broke
his restraining order by showing up
during the baby set
and so uh oh cause she did a song with
the baby she did a song with the baby
but they were both performing at a music
festival turlene's was not supposed to
be here he then showed up and that was
an issue within the confines of his
restraining order with meghan the
stallion so
it affects his probation she said she
feared the cops would shoot tory if she
told him that black man uh had a gun and
had shot at her well he's facing uh
oh god damn you wanna see him holy [ __ ]
yeah
yeah we can roll with it oh my god he
really shot the [ __ ] out of here it
looks like a shrapnel right yeah i don't
think yeah like the burrito sucks